sit up
for the second time in a matter of days
a suspect dies in Dallas police custody
of our answer dispatch partner yes
[Music]
the suspect six
feet
updated address as long crime Network
reported 39 year old Xavier Franklin
died in Dallas police custody on June
21st after he was taken into custody and
later questioned about a murder
investigation
what would you like us to do for you
today
right
just days later on June 28th
seventy-year-old Roy Whitaker also died
in Dallas police custody
just
ambulance coming sir relax
please
just before 1 30 that morning officials
say Whitaker was involved in a hit and
run crash First Responders say Whitaker
crashed into another vehicle then drove
off dash camera video shows an officer
follow Whitaker and motion for him to
pull over I'll be right back
[Music]
yeah body camera video then shows the
responding officers speaking to Whitaker
for the first time
hey man you know I'm pulling over
[Music]
you have no clue
okay you're a driver license insurance
covered
where are you coming from I just left
bingo
okay version incense
car of insurance huh this car have
insurance uh yeah it is who I make my
car payments
okay try to find you okay
eventually Whitaker steps out of the
vehicle
find your insurance
huh
what's up with the car Roy ah step out
the car but
leave all that stuff over there just
leave it over there
don't have no guns
okay come on over here
comes the rain
keep your feet up for me
support and put your hands cross them
there you go
what he did
wrong the officers
are involved in
a hitch Whittaker initially denies what
would I do sir you hit that car I didn't
hit that car I saw you hit that guy hit
each other sir okay
okay
that's that's why they that's why they
left we didn't hit each other you hit
them we didn't hit each other I was
behind you officer you want me to show
you the damage on your car yes okay come
on over
come on over here you come you come over
me
you didn't make contact okay what is
that
what is that
you told me that was like that
no that wasn't like that
I saw you hit him trying to burn off
yeah but then the other car burned off
on us
come on yeah you did you took off this
way
have a seat have a seat I'm gonna see if
they show up or not have a seat
have a seat cross your legs put your
hands on your knees stay right there
don't move
yeah yeah I got them after running his
information officers find out Whitaker
had misdemeanor warrants out for his
arrest he's then taken into custody
hi Mr Whitaker you got some warrants
we're gonna take care of okay keep your
hands back here by your back I got some
warrant yeah I don't have anymore sir
I'm telling you do so
uh Dallas
that's not a warrant sir yeah you got
him and I'm taking you on them okay can
I can I explain what they do that's
about it yeah okay I'll find out okay
I'll stand up I can fix them okay one
two three
okay
you didn't go yet
Colorado
son I've seen wearing a black shirt and
black shorts but saying that he wants to
caramel development at the time it was
approximated
sitting in a gray Kia two-door
he has not been diagnosed with anything
but yeah I should have Commit is several
times in the past yes Mr Whitaker I'm
gonna search you guys all your knuckles
have
anything legal in the car you're not
supposed to have
okay
minutes later Whitaker can be heard
coughing
foreign
officials then ask Whitaker if he has
any medical conditions
what's your condition what you need help
do you have any medical issues yeah what
you have
I'll put them on
after that officers call for an
ambulance
answer dispatch partner yes
[Music]
that's like six six
three please
updated address
[Music]
on here
mom Service Road westbound
please
ambulance coming sir just relax
officials then remove the handcuffs from
Whitaker's wrists
Judy likes everyone is coming
[Music]
come on rookie uncomfortable
yes
okay can we uncut them we're gonna keep
them on his right side in the recovery
position what should I say
um and come for him and keeping the
right sample recovery question exactly
all right
okay First Responders put Whitaker in
what they call the quote recovery
position as they wait for the ambulance
to arrive hey boss man listen listen to
me hey
want to put you in the recovery position
all right we're gonna scooch you down
off this curve all right
future down off this car a few doors
please go towards me there you go the
blade on your side lay down on your side
you're good you're good okay wait on
your side ambulance is coming you ain't
gotta worry okay
hey what kind of medical problems you
got
what kind of medical problems you got
boss
okay well that's that is unfortunate
anything besides okay do you take
medication
do you take medication when's the last
time you got your medication
this morning how often he's supposed to
be taking it
yeah you did Bailey okay
well if you got his match
let's relax is on the way when EMS
responders first get there officers
explain what happened
what's going on buddy
good how are you
[Music]
okay let's watch the story I guess
basically he hit another car all Squad
unit
foreign
[Music]
my helper
wow
sit up
speed underneath
survival
okay
well you got your cups back right all
right
next to our location
another phone
[Music]
eventually Whitaker becomes unresponsive
foreign
[Music]
Whitaker arrived at the hospital at 2 27
a.m minutes later at 2 42 he was
pronounced dead officials say an autopsy
and toxicology report have not yet been
returned in the case the incident is now
under investigation by the Dallas Police
Special investigations unit reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie